[Musique]
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur france 3 bourgogne sur la
page facebook de france 3 pour ce rendez
vous spécial législatives
nous nous intéressons aujourd'hui à la
saône et loire en partenariat avec nos
confrères du journal de saône et loire
et nous avons choisi d'amener notre
plateau sur place nous sommes ici au
creusot sur l'esplanade de l'arc la
scène nationale et nous ouvrons tout de
suite le premier débat avec la 5e
circonscription de saône et loire chalon
montceau circonscription redécoupée
avant 2012 sommes des anciennes 4e et 5e
quatorze candidats se présenter par
mieux nos invités christophe sirugue
bonjour vous êtes depuis 2007 pour le ps
le député de la circonscription
secrétaire d'état à l'industrie dans
l'équipe sortante rajoutons que vous
avez été maire de chalon maire de chalon
avant gilles platret bonjour bonjour
vous êtes l'actuel maire de chalon sur
saône et candidats les républicains
raphaël gauvin bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le candidat de la république en marche
pour cette élection
eric riboulet bonjour bonjour candidat
de la france insoumise nathalie vermorel
bonjour vous porter les couleurs du
parti communiste et nathalie zik pour le
front national bon jour en jour où les
électeurs ne vous connaissent pas encore
forcément tous et toutes nous vous
proposons donc de vous présentez nous
dire quelles sont vos motivations
on va faire ça vite il va falloir être
con si vous disposez de 30 secondes en
commençant par vous christophe sirugue
on permettrait une pensée pour les
victimes des attentats de londres hier
car je crois qu'ils seraient rien depuis
préjudiciable que d'oublier et de
considérer ces actes odieux finalement
comme habituel cela étant j'ai été
durant cinq ans le représentant de ce
territoire et de ses habitants
je suis né ici issu d'un milieu modeste
et c'est par mon travail par ma ténacité
que j'ai pu assumer les responsabilités
et beaucoup quelle que soit leur
sensibilité me reconnaisse ses qualités
il se trouve que c'est ma conception de
la fonction et du plus loin que je me
souvienne j'ai eu à coeur de prendre ma
part aux objectifs et aux enjeux qui
sont collectifs et je crois qu'avec ma
suppléante catherine golfeur nous
voulons cette fois-ci mobiliser notre
connaissance mobiliser notre intensité
d'actions pour permettre de répondre aux
enjeux de cette circonscription
merci gilles platret
rebonjour s'il fallait résumer en 30
secondes ce qui est une gageur je vous
dirais que par mon parcours je suis un
candidat de terrain suis aussi issus de
ses treize jours depuis toujours ma
famille est installée depuis des siècles
et les fonctions que j'ai exercées
notamment sur le plan municipal m'amène
à considérer que la politique ne se
conçoit qu'avec les gens c'est à dire
les vrais gens qu'on peut pas comme ça
tombait du ciel de paris avec un
parachute pour dire je veux vous
représentez il faut être issu du terrain
écouter et c'est peut-être même encore
plus important que d'être de droite ou
de gauche
d'abord être proche des préoccupations
des gens c'est ce que je suis super de
chalon vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure et c'est pour moi une
préoccupation quotidienne que je veut
désormais étendre à l'échelle de
l'ensemble la circonscription la
proximité et la parole du terrain
apparaît essentiel dans le contexte
national qui est qu'il est aujourd'hui
merci raphaël gauvin à vous alors
rappelle gauvin je suis candidat en
marche
j'ai 44 ans je suis chalonnais et je
suis le candidat de la société civile
j'ai jamais été élu j'ai jamais fait
campagne m'est arrivé de voter à droite
de voter à gauche et je suis le candidat
pour porter le projet présidentiel du
président et pour reprendre leur
présenter notre territoire
merci eric des boulets bonjour donc
eryck rebbouh l'est je suis magasinier
préparateurs de commandes je suis donc
au moins aussi issus de la société
civile
pas celle de monsieur macron les avocats
des professions libérales je suis de
celles qui se lèvent tous des
agriculteurs qui travaille beaucoup les
4 moyens c'est tous ces gens qui
travaillent beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
ne peuvent pas vivre décemment
je suis candidat de la france insoumise
et le soutient le programme maintenir en
commun est ma devise
écoutez considérer agir merci nathalie
vermorel
oui bonjour moi je suis assistante
sociale travaillent dans le secteur
privé et je m'occupe essentiellement du
milieu agricole
je suis la candidate du parti communiste
français avec une double ambition
d'abord être proches de ceux qui me
ressemblent à ceux qui s'inquiètent de
leur travail de leur revenu ceux qui se
battent contre les politiques
d'austérité ce qui pour qui les
politiques publiques et l'économie
devrait déjà être au service des gens
dans la réponse aux besoins des
populations avant d'être au service de
l'enrichissement personnel de
quelques-uns et l'ambition la deuxième
ambition que j'ai c'est celle de
travailler avec tous les citoyens ou
pour construire des propositions qui
soient en fait le prolongement de leurs
revendications
merci nathalie fixez-vous qui conclut et
ses présentations
oui bonjour je suis donc nathalie zik je
suis candidate pour le front national
j'ai 50 ans je suis mère de deux enfants
je suis dans la vie de tous les jours
secrétaire médicale j'ai fait deux
campagnes électorales départementales et
régionales en 2015 et je serai bien
évidement là ça fait plus d'un an que
nous sommes sur le terrain avec lilian
noirot qui est mon suppléant et je serai
une députée patriotes pour contrer tous
les toutes les mauvaises actions au
parlement de revenir
merci pour cette introduction pour ses
présentations rentrons maintenant dans
le coeur du débat avec d'abord un
chapitre très politique une situation
nationale inédite qui justifie de vous
demander finalement vous vous situez les
uns et les autres majorité-opposition
refus éventuel des premières mesures
annoncées
gilles platret ya un premier ministre de
droite et vous vous êtes tous dans cette
élection
moi je suis au gouvernement ça vous a
pas échappé on est aujourd'hui dans un
brouillage politique énorme c'est sur le
terrain quand on discute avec les gens
c'est d'abord la première des choses qui
nous font remonter c'est l'éclatement
des déchets vin traditionnel
le président de la république a été élu
personne ne conteste son élection il a
été largement mais à la faveur d'un
affrontement contre l'extrême droite qui
réduit forcément la porte et personnels
de cette élection
donc il a essayé de faire éclater un
certain nombre de formations parti
socialiste est absorbée à mes yeux par
part en marche
le parti républicain a tenu parce que il
a essayé évidemment par la nomination de
trois ministres républicain drôle
premier de faire éclater la famille ça
n'a pas marché aujourd'hui
ce qui nous importe c'est que la france
réussisse il faut un président qui
préside
il existe mais il faut aussi un
gouvernement qui gouverne et qui
gouverne en fonction de ce que les
français veulent
et ça ça me paraît essentielle c'est
tout l'enjeu des 11 et 18 ans prochain
et je suis favorable à ce qu'une
majorité très clair s'exprime pour une
vision politique partagée par l'ensemble
des français
merci gilles platret raphaël gauvin
vous avez dit tout à l'heure j'ai voté à
gauche j'ai voté à droite parfois vous
êtes un homme de gauche vous êtes un
homme de droite vous vous situez vous
moi je suis marcheurs je crois
profondément que le dépassement des
vieux clivages partisans
droite gauche vont nous permettre de
réformer la société
c'est au coeur dans l'adn du projet
macron et je crois profondément que pour
réformer la société
il faut qu'on arrive à faire la synthèse
entre des propositions de droite des
propositions de gauche on a un président
qui est issu de la gauche
un premier ministre issu de la droite
libérale modéré je crois profondément
que c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera à
faire les réformes
moi je suis issu de la société civile je
vous le dis franchement ce que je vous
ai dit dans ma dent may dans mon
introduction m'est arrivé de voter à
droite
il m'est arrivé de voter à gauche mais
aujourd'hui je crois profondément que
c'est comme ça qu'on va réformer le pays
et retrouver dans quelques années
enfin à l'issue du quinquennat une
société apaisée
alors christophe sirugue forcément c'est
à vous que je pose la question derrière
opposition pour gilles platret en marche
pour raphaël gauvin vous serez avec
lequel d'entre eux éventuellement
d'abord je crois que dans une période où
en effet beaucoup de nos concitoyens
s'interroge je crois qu'il faut être soi
même
il faut éviter de se donner finalement
une consistance par rapport à un
contexte où un vent qui serait favorable
moi je suis socialiste et j'envisage
bien évidemment tout au long de cette
campagne de redire ce que sont mes
valeurs
ce qu'est mon engagement mais en même
temps le président macron doit réussir
son quinquennat au risque autrement
d'avoir dans cinq ans finalement ceux
qui nous expliquent ayant essayé la
droite ayant essayé la gauche s'ils
veulent proposer autre chose et je ne me
viennent évidemment satisfait pas de ces
éléments là mais le président macron dit
je suis et de droite et de gauche
et bien moi je veux être le et de gauche
de cette proposition qui nous est faite
merci eric riboulet
l'opposition plutôt pour vous dans la
ville tout dépend du résultat du 18 juin
six hommes manoeuvre minoritaire à
l'assemblée on serait donc dans
l'opposition mais nous sommes sur cette
campagne ce que vous dites aujourd'hui
aux gens que vous rencontrez c'est une
opposition déjà à emmanuel macron nous
on y croit toujours
moi quand je me lance dans une campagne
où c'est pour gagner et je veux dire
c'est pas pour dire je vais te deuxième
dans ses bottes le premier c'est un
point c'est tout mais nous serons pas
une opposition pure dur juste pour nous
opposer
si le président macron fait des lois qui
vont dans le sens de votre programme
l'avenir en commun comme le sortie du
nucléaire le 100 % bio et tout ça aux
électeurs dont on parle c'est plutôt le
code du travail en ce moment ci cost
code du travail par contre là on sera en
face de lui il verra il verra la france
insoumise
contre lui et 100 % environ on va pas
travailler nos électeurs on n'est pas
comme certains pour une place pour
quelques quelques places au sénat
quelques places au conseil municipal ont
trahi nos électeurs nous on n'a eu
qu'une seule cause d'une seule
id notre programme c'est la clarté et la
cohérence la transparence donc voilà
nathalie vermorel
qu'est ce qui vous différencie dans
cette campagne parti communiste de la
france a soumise c'est pas la question à
laquelle je vais répondre je vais vous
dire comme monsieur mc ren il
et voyez il a ni droite ni gauche mais
il est pas venu chercher le parti
communiste vous pensez que votre
gouvernement répond ok je vous répondrai
donc pour nous à la tête de l'état c'est
de bras armé des milieux financiers et
des affaires il a choisi deux ministres
de droite pour verrouiller bercy et
matignon ont très clairement elle n'a
montré antérieurement dans les lois
qu'il a pris c'est un libéral
forcément le parti communiste va être
très clairement dans une opposition aux
politiques libérales et comme vous le
rappeliez justement avant sa première
son premier hat c'est de demander le
droit au parlement de procéder par
ordonnance pour à nouveau taclé le droit
du travail et la protection des salariés
alors mais j'ai bien mais qu'est ce qui
vous différencie d'eric riboulet dans ce
qu'est ce qui différencie d'eric
riboulet dans cette campagne c'est
qu'eric riboulet et informations france
a soumises n'a pas voulu discuter de
propositions et de candidature commune
alors que nous avons des axes
programmatiques extrêmement lent
rassemble et genre de chacun son temps
de parole et je regrette cette position
parce que sinon je pense que nous
aurions pu faire un bon travail
collectif
donc voilà donc aujourd'hui moi je porte
ce que le parti communiste or depuis 70
ans ce rush ce territoire c'est à dire
une candidature claire nette en faveur
du monde ouvrier et du monde des
salariés nathalie zik front national en
tête au premier tour de la
présidentielle sur cette circonscription
on va dire le peu de vent en marche par
rapport à d'autres circonscriptions
ça vous donne une responsabilité pour
ces élections législatives alors
effectivement j'ai une grosse
responsabilité
j'ai une excellente équipe avec moi qui
me soutient tous les jours sur le
terrain
nous sommes bien évidemment
persuadé que nous serons nombreux au
parlement pour contrer toutes les
mauvaises
loi qui seront données par le président
macron entre parenthèses pour la loi du
travail nous sommes tout à fait contre
la nouvelle loin qu'il veut mettre par
ordonnance
ce n'est pas du tout comme ça que nous
voulons les choses on veut de la
discussion et et remettre les
la population qu'ils soient consultés
sur ces problématiques
donc c'est pour nous c'est important
donc effectivement je ferai partie de
l'image de la part de la majorité mais
de là l'opposition et on espère être
majoritaire gilles platret dans les
premières mesures annoncées il ya des
choses qui vous semblent positives des
choses négatif vous en parlez dans votre
campagne des législatives on se le dit
très rapidement avant de passer à la
suite de l'émission mais en quelques
mots écoutez aujourd'hui on est sur un
gouvernement provisoire qui a été nommé
et comme à chaque fois d'ailleurs après
une élection présidentielle dans la
tente des législatives
c'est à gouvernement en vitrine qui
associe un certain nombre de
personnalités fortes pour donner un sens
à une image au président de la
république on sait très bien que ce
gouvernement quoi qu'il advienne
quoi qu'il advienne changera de toute
façon après le 18 juin il y aura des
ajustements
donc permettez moi simplement de dire
qu'on va attendre le résultat des
élections mais je voudrais quand même
puisque vous me donnez la parole
posez une question le second vent
monsieur gauvin nous dit j'ai voté à
droite j'ai voté à gauche
moi j'aimerais savoir pour qui vous
allez voter dimanche prochain le second
vin je vais voter pour le candidat en
marche et c'est qui votre candidat en
marche
non je voulais juste avoir vous êtes
inscrits sur les listes électorales
messieurs vous manque que les gens sages
conseils vous ne pourrez même pas vos
clés pour vous parce que vous êtes
inscrit à paris je suis loin des députés
hors sol des candidats qui se présentent
alors qu'ils ne peuvent même pas voter
pour eux parce qu'ils soient paris
répond suis désolé ça va pas on fait
répondre à fait le droit
oui non c'est un faux procès qu'on fait
moi je pense que je représente la
société
aujourd'hui les gens y vivent dans un
territoire et puis après ils partent
faire leurs études travailler moi je me
suis mal être et je suis chalonnais j'ai
vécu toute mon enfance ici j'étais à
l'école du centre
j'étais haqqani a ponte us ensuite je
suis parti j'ai fait mes études j'ai
travaillé appris un métier j'ai créé un
cabinet j'ai créé des emplois et j'en
suis très fier et aujourd'hui je reviens
ici avec mon expérience pour apporter
mon expérience à mon territoire et et je
veux me mettre au service de la france
avec le président macron est au service
de mon territoire
en cas d'achat moiron s'inscrit son
l'électoral monsieur commencer
le premier des respects avoir peur aux
électeurs ça fait 20 ans que vous êtes
parti vous n'aviez même pas pu répondre
à la mer du chalonnais pour savoir
quelles rues se trouver votre permanence
s'il vous plaît gériatre et shannon est
il simplement pas très rapide si on peut
éviter d'avoir un débat très monsieur
grâce à cet accord parce que si vous
permet un monde c'est d'abord pour
revenir à votre question dans les
positionnements qui sont annoncées par
le gouvernement il ya des éléments qui
me paraissent fort la moralisation de la
vie politique c'est un engagement fort
par contre le fait de proposer des
ordonnances sur des sujets aussi
sensibles que ceux qui sont en
discussion me paraît être quelque chose
d'inacceptable
mais je voudrais quand même revenir sur
cette moralisation de la vie politique
la moralisation de la vie politique
c'est aussi ce que les candidats ont
comme comportement quand
en effet on a été absent du territoire
chalonnais pendant 20 ans et qu'on y
revient pour les repas de famille et
qu'on nous explique que c'est comme ça
qu'on va représenter le territoire ça me
paraît quand même limite mais la même
façon monsieur platret quand on est
candidat il ya trois ans pour être mère
à 100% et qu'on envisage maintenant de
lettres à 0%
je trouve que c'est pas une manière que
de considérer les citoyens et citoyennes
de ce territoire donc à un moment il
faut avoir de la loyauté avec ce
territoire faut avoir de l'engagement
pour ce territoire et il me semble que
ce territoire il a besoin de ça il a
besoin de gens qui ne font pas leur
carrière personnelle avant l'intérêt
général vous êtes bien placé pour le
dire mais ceux ci auraient que vous qui
avait été battu au premier tour des
élections municipales
vous étiez verra combien vous quand vous
étiez en exercice en sacrant bien je
suis bien je n'avais combien de maires
associés d'accord la maman j'ai peur
qu'il sait sur quel jeu complet très
vite vous deviez vous laisser trop cage
mais en permanence débuté l année
trancheront a laissé rupture à combien
maintenant à 10% donnerait boulet
lorsque vous s'il vous plaît ce qu'elle
est agressif comme vous l'êtes
régulièrement et pont pourra discuter
comme moi on avance donc pas mes
électeurs on avance dans notre émission
s'il vous plaît c'est faux
avoir des gens pour une photo montage
aux journalistes au journal de saône et
loire pour parler de la circonscription
un petit peu plus mais c'était bien et
on a déjà parlé de la circonscription en
réalité avec vos ancrage aux uns et aux
autres je le disais en ouverture découpé
en 2012 ya bien sûr chalon y'a aussi
montceau benoît dans cette
circonscription
mais le poids de chalon bien sûr le
poids de chalon la plus grosse ville de
saône et loire donc si vous le voulez
bien on va parler un peu de cette
circonscription est le problème du
moment celui en tout cas qui fait la une
de l'actualité notamment les grosses
difficultés que rencontrent l'hôpital de
montceau les mines
vous avez tous plus ou moins pris
position sur cette question
la question qui se pose derrière les
difficultés du jour c'est comment demain
montceau les mines sur cette question
l'hôpital où les autres ne va pas se
faire un peu avalé par chalon sur saône
vous voulez tout le tous être député à
100% et chalon et de montceau j'ai envie
de demander à raphaël gauvin tout à
l'heure on vous demander si vous étiez
assez chalonnais je vais vous demander
si vous êtes assez mons et bien et
surtout fait partie de ceux qui disent
il faut que l'hôpital de chalon et
l'hôpital de montceau les mines
fusionnent oui oui je pense que c'est le
on a vu le représentant des rs de
bourgogne vendredi dernier je pense que
c'est le évidemment le chance dans la
réorganisation des soins il faut que la
l'hôpital de chalon et de montceau
réorganiser des soins et à terme je
crois que c'est en 2018
bon c'est un projet qui est ambitieux
parce que ça va coûter de l'argent
public pour sauver l'hôpital de montceau
mais ça va être le rôle du député dans
les dé la le mur jean scinder qui sera
élu mais de porter ce projet à paris
dans les services centraux et pour que
ce projet ambitieux pour sauver
l'hôpital de montceau soit garanti
gilles platret vous étiez l'autre jour
vous êtes emparés de cette question vous
êtes aujourd'hui maire de chalon ne
serait plus si vous êtes élu député
comment le potentiel député de demain
pourra à la fois défendre et chalon et
montceau sur un thème comme celui
l'hôpital la question qui se posait pas
exactement celle ci si vous me permettez
monsieur mental je dis aujourd'hui nous
avons à l'hôpital de montceau qui est en
déficit structurel et qui porte le poids
de tête qui sont très très lourde
la difficulté
et qu'il ya c'est d'assurer la pérennité
site établissements d'autant qu'il ya un
programme d'investissement très lourd a
assuré sur les bâtiments si on veut le
maintenir à niveau
ça c'est l'équation qu'il faut résoudre
moi j'entends monsieur commun qui dit
faux la fusion moi je sais pas si c'est
la fusion qui nous sauvera ce qu'il faut
d'abord c'est que on arrive à redonner à
l'hôpital de man sous une perspective
ça passera par une coopération renforcée
à chalon vous savez que je suis
président du conseil de surveillance de
l'hôpital de chalon nous avons déjà des
coopérations renforcées avec montceau le
but c'est de les accroître encore il
n'est pas question qu'il y ait
d'absorption le territoire dont ce lien
est un bassin de vie qui a besoin d'un
hôpital de proximité donc le but ça
n'est pas que chalon absent le manceau
sait qu'il ya une répartition des modes
opératoires qui est une répartition des
publics en fonction des typologies
d'actes réalisés mais en restant le plus
proche possible des bassins dis moi j'y
suis favorable est en tout cas chalon a
déjà montré la voie et doit continuer
c'est le sens en tout cas de la position
que je défends que j'ai exprimée
notamment de nathalie vermorel vous
étiez l'autre jour aux côtés des
salariés de l'hôpital de montceau les
mines
pour vous quelle est la solution pour
sauver l'hôpital de montceau et pour que
concrètement les gens qui habitent
autour de montceau les mines ne soit pas
obligé dans 5 ans 10 ans d'aller à
chalon systématiquement oui oui moi je
pense que vraiment les l'hôpital de
montceau mais tous les hôpitaux sont
dans la même situation depuis les lois
santé de madame bachelot et de madame
touraine
on a là dans cette problématique des
hôpitaux
une mise en lumière de l'inefficacité
totale des politiques libérales
actuelles on à la concurrence entre les
territoires au lieu de la coopération ça
soit les cloches de phase i quand on
voit à chalon deux hôpitaux l'un dijon
l'autre à mâcon qui font un procès pour
que chalon ne soit pas dotées du plateau
technique qui convient pour traiter la
cardiologie on est dans la concurrence
on est dans la gestion comptable
beaucoup plus dans le rationnement des
soins que dans la rationalisation et
sain c'est au lieu de la réponse aux
besoins de la population et troisième
point on est dans la concentration au
lieu d'un maillage territoire renforcer
alors moi je pense que cette question de
la dette des hôpitaux publics
ça me rappelle terriblement la dette de
la sncf elle ne se réglera que par des
moratoires est la remise en cause de la
tarification à l'activité qui
structurellement génèrent ces
problématiques l'ado merci moi je ne
soutiens pas ce projet de fusion
christophe sirugue sur cette question
est ce qu'elle est et ce qu'elle est
réelle cette concurrence entre les
territoires de chalon et de montceau les
mines
c'est un sujet que je suis depuis des
années puisque je rappelle que j'ai été
à l'origine de la création du groupement
d'hospitalisation territoriales parce
que il y avait besoin de faire
travailler les établissements dotés de
chalon et de montceau l'ensemble et il
me semble que pour répondre à votre
question il ya trois impératifs
d'abord il faut assainir la situation
financière de montceau les mines
parce que si on ne fait pas cela c'est
évident que d'autres centres
hospitaliers n'auront pas envie de
travailler et de penser
finalement du centre hospitalier de
montceau mais deux il faut reconnaître
que montceau depuis des années et des
années a subi à la fois des décisions
des contres décision qui lui ont été
préjudiciables et donc il faut que le
projet médical soit respect à la fois
des habitants du territoire montcellien
de la proximité dont nous a joints dont
nous avons besoin et d'une offre de
soins diverses et de qualité et bien
comment nous pouvons vite à lier moi je
suis favorable à un rapprochement des
trois centres hospitaliers
mais merci que ça tire et nathalie zik
je voulais rappeler quelque chose vous
étiez initialement candidate sur la 4e
circonscription celle de la bresse on
est loin montceau les mines
est ce que cette question l'hôpital de
montceau les mines c'est un sujet dont
vous êtes emparés récemment que vous
connaissez bien
oui bien effectivement c'est un sujet
que je ne connais très bien puisque je
suis secrétaire médicale donc au niveau
du monde médical j'ai quand même
beaucoup de connaissances
le problème que je vais changer de
circonscription n'est pas le sujet
aujourd'hui de toute façon je j'habite à
saint rémy et je suis allée de vendredi
avec lilian noirot sur le site de
l'hôpital de montceau les mines pour
justement être aux côtés des du
personnel il ya un sujet qui m'ennuie
fortement dans ce entend tout ce que je
viens d'entendre c'est qu'on oublie une
chose essentielle c'est le l'usager
l'usagé de l'hôpital et
il est intolérable qu'un patient de
montceau les mines doivent se déplacer
face vingt trente quarante kilomètres
pour pouvoir se soigner se soigner c'est
une chose mais quand on est dans une
situation délicate après des soins
on a besoin d'être entouré par sa
famille donc si on fait des kilomètres
on est plus éloigné donc c'est un
problème important
donc évidemment il ya un problème
financier mais il faut pas oublier le
l'usager et eryck rebbouh les alors on
va vous poser l'accasion la même
question tout à l'heure mais est-ce que
vous êtes sur la même ligne que le parti
communiste sur sur cette question je
rejoins nathalie vermorel en disant que
les difficultés les hôpitaux de chalon
et de montceau sont les mêmes que ceux
de paris de nevers où d'ailleurs quand
je dire ils viennent des différents
plans d'austérité qu'on a fait ce qu'on
a subi par les gouvernements sarkozy
hollande
et je rappelle qu autour de cette table
quand même de deux candidats qui ont
soutenu ces gouvernements
donc il faut être lucide lucide c'est
pas aux patients d'aller à la santé ça
l'a senti qui doit aller au patient veut
dire il faut pour pas pour éviter que
les patients face 40 km pour soigner ou
parce qu'elles ont besoin de leur
famille ils ont besoin de d'être entouré
de personnes qui qui connaissent que le
dit déjà que les aides soignants sont de
plus en plus difficiles sont de plus en
plus concis comment dire que sont plus
en plus pris part le par le monde le
monde du travail parce qu'il y en a de
moins en moins les infirmiers c'est
pareil
l'autre jour à un acte orient me disait
bientôt on va nous dire de passer devant
les portes et puis de lancer les filets
les seringue parce qu'elles n'auront pas
le temps de s'occuper de leurs patients
et ça je trouve ça pas normal merci
raphael gobât un petit mot sur l'
équilibre de ce territoire entre châlons
est-ce que chalon a pas tendance à
écraser un peu le reste du territoire
est-ce que c'est pas une difficulté le
fait que ce que chalon écrase pas un peu
le reste du territoire finalement ou
est-ce que ces deux locomotives
non non il faut il faut évidemment que
chalon c'est la première ville du
département il faut que chalon et ce
rôle moteur retrouve un avenir un espoir
et dans entraîne avec lui
le territoire de montsouris l'exemple
que vous avez pris sur la santé c'est là
on à chalon a été construit une dizaine
d'années cet hôpital c'est l'hôpital
pivot du département mais on doit avoir
cet hôpital pivot qui se développe
et puis ne pas oublier le territoire de
moncheaux et la proximité des soins sur
montceau christophe sirugue un tout
petit mot là dessus
au fait ils sont partis je voudrais sous
comme n'oublie pas que cette
circonscription ceci aussi des
territoires ruraux et que certes il ya
chalon certes il ya un bon saut il ya
tous les secteurs de buxy toutes ces
petites communes qui ont aussi besoin
bien évidemment lorsque l'on parle d'
enjeu sanitaire que l'on réfléchisse à
la problématique de la démographie
médicale de l'absence de médecin de la
mise en place de maisons de santé
et si on oublie que cette
circonscription certes elle a besoin de
locomotives et chalon en est une elle a
besoin d'avoir des points d'appui le
bassin minier en est un elle a aussi ses
territoires ruraux dont je ne voudrais
pas qu'on les oublie dans ce débat merci
christophe sirugue on arrive à la fin de
ce débat comme prévu passé en conclusion
30 secondes chacun dans un ordre tirés
au sort préalablement merci de respecter
cette règle stricte des trente secondes
et on commence par vous christophe
sirugue
merci vous le savez j'ai porté des
dossiers essentiels au niveau national
et au niveau local rcea question
hospitalière le développement économique
l'accompagnement des projets des
communes les plus petites notamment et
je les fais toujours en essayant
d'associer toutes celles et tous ceux
qui participent de la dynamique du
territoire
c'est cet état d'esprit que je veux
continuer à développer d'abord parce que
nous avons un territoire qui a un
potentiel qui a des atouts parce que
nous devons faire ce qu'il faut pour
permettre de redonner de l'espoir et
puis en même temps être député c'est
aussi être présent au niveau national et
moi je veux être celui qui a sur ce
point d'équilibré entre les évolutions
qui sont nécessaires parce que la
société l'exigent et en même temps les
protections indispensables pour chacun
merci christophe sirugue raphaël gauvin
avant de conclure je crois que
l'élection des manuels macron a fait
quelques semaines maintenant que je suis
sur le terrain que je vais à la
rencontre des dés de nos concitoyens et
ce que je ressens par dessus tout c'est
et moi ma volonté c'est de porter en
tant que député porter cette fierté et
de conduire les réformes dont le pays a
besoin et d'assurer un nouveau dynamisme
sur notre territoire pour porter les
dossiers la circonscription
merci raphaël gobain mataly zik ça vous
de conclure alors député de la nation
avec les lions noirot je prendrai mon
mandat très à coeur et je serai présente
à 100% à l'assemblée nationale ce que je
voulais dire par rapport à papa j'ai pas
pu le dire tout à l'heure mais un député
également un député de la nation il
n'est pas que le député de la
circonscription et je ferais je mettrai
tout en ordre pour contrer les mauvaises
actions du programme macro et là je
donne tout son soutien pour les
personnes qui sont encore endeuillé par
rapport aux problèmes l'attentât qui les
a eus hier soir et la jette un grand
travail que nous devrons faire très
rapidement pour remettre les choses en
ordre à ce sujet merci nathalie zik eric
rigoler c'est à vous de conclure bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla trente années de
même discours trente années de même
pratique politique trente années de
promesses non tenues pour en arriver où
là où nous sommes à une france qui
désespère et une france qui n'a plus de
rêve une france qui ne fait plus rêver
certes je ne suis pas un politique pro
certes je n'ai pas de cravate sur moi
mais dans ma poche je n'ai pas misé pour
la bonne et simple raison c'est que moi
je veux être moi je veux être moi pour
vous les électeurs alors certes je n'ai
pas d'expérience certes je bafouille
peut-être un peu mais il ne faut pas
oublier qu'il ya quand même quelques
semaines les français ont élu un jeune
sans expérience président de la
république merci gilles platret un
député c'est une double exigence à mes
yeux en tout cas d'abord celle de
contrôler l'action du gouvernement est
votée la loi
vous avez bien compris que quelle que
soit la majorité qui sortira des urnes
le 18 juin je serai à députés exigent je
veux 13 qui me paraîtra juste je
repousserai ce qui me paraît très
injuste quelle que soit la configuration
que les choses soient bien claires mais
c'est aussi le représentant de sa
population
nous avons besoin le territoire de
montceau de buxy de chalon ont besoin
d'un député présent à paris pour
défendre les intérêts des communes pour
représenter ses citoyens et dans la
proximité
j'aurai trois permanences je
rencontrerai les gens en direct comme je
lé fais à la mairie de chalon sur saône
le député la proximité c'est aussi celui
du terrain merci j'ai le plâtre et
nathalie vermorel c'est vous qui conclut
les conclusions oui donc logique pour
moi de cette législative c'est qu'on
puisse choisir des députés de gauche qui
sont résister au projet libéraux et de
déréglementation débridée qu'après vieux
monsieur macro qui seront aussi au sein
de l'assemblée ratio national est
capable de rassembler sans sectarisme ni
hégémonie pour constituer un pôle de
résistance et de propositions à
l'assemblée
alors je crois que j'ai démontré depuis
10 ans à travers à la fois mais
responsabilité politique mon engagement
et mon précédent mandat
conseiller régional que j'étais capable
à la fois de porter est de faire vivre
ces trois dimensions la résistance la
proposition progressiste et le
rassemblement
et c'est la force de cet engagement
honnête sincère que je ma disposition
des électeurs de gauche aujourd'hui
merci nathalie vermorel merci à tous
d'avoir accepté notre invitation pour ce
débat qui va très vite je le vois dans
vos requêtes et pendant que vous quittez
ce plateau je chasse en fait en quelque
sorte benoît tout à l'heure qui précise
que huit autres candidats ce procès et
avec des applaudissements vous le voyez
en en public au creusot que huit autres
candidats se présentent sur cette
deuxième sur cette circonscription
il s'agit de pascal dufresne lutte
ouvrière françois lotteau europe
écologie m
durieux aux peid arnaud mignardi veut
allonger nyons marianne l'aco ghislaine
launay samuel brandily et samuel k alors